peu
[Musique]
sarkozy
à vannes
trois questions et services ont joué
certains coups c'est non plus caché à
bram
si vous savez pas qui c'est il connaît
pas catching tales l'ipad mais la france
entière que lesquels chou n'a pas moi et
on va voir vous allez voir vous allez
aimer les ravissants elle est ravie sont
pas vraiment c'est a alors dormi chez
entendu parler d'elle à noter non ça me
revient cache où on ne fait pas la météo
non elle fait la pluie et le beau temps
mais ne fait pas la météo cash ou ne
m'appelez plus jamais katchou quoi on en
peut plus vous application c'est pas
vrai ça c'est les journaux qui ont écrit
ça j'ai jamais dis ne m'appelez plus
qu'à chaud je renie pas ce que j'ai fait
oui j'ai un fort juste que mon vrai nom
san charpente a brillé gelé repris pense
que cela montre en même temps pour à
votre avis pour passer de quechua anne
charlotte pontabry parce que l'euro ça
va prendre trois ans je crois donc si
j'ai beaucoup de mal moi aussi mais je
sais pas toute façon les gens choix ils
peuvent continuer à rappeler cash ou
s'ils préfèrent alors cachou c1 c'est un
surnom que vous avez donné votre votre
père quand vous avez une jaunisse ouais
en fait non oui c'est pas si c'est
vraiment failli s'appeler rugby non je
sais pas si c'est vraiment que la raison
en tous les cas c'est vrai que je suis
né avec la jaunisse comme certains
enfants vous êtes né avec le joli mais
ça arrive je n'en sais rien mais c'est
parti mais donc voilà oui effectivement
c'est un sens non compères l année quand
j'étais voilà alors le papa de ketch ou
sait qu'il va pas le cacher c'est le
monsieur qui vivait avec la maman
d'ophélie monsieur qui vivait avec la
maman de fait à vide avec 5 non non non
non pas du tout mais pas ça non c'est un
monsieur s'énoncer votre papa il vivait
avec la maman d'ophélie après
après david avec sandrine terme c'est ça
compliqué c'est très compliqué il faut
lire voici assidûment faut prendre des
notes et tous côte ouest
j'aurais pas toutes ces fichiers
vêtements honnêtement je n'arriverai pas
à faut dire la vérité
vous pouvez poser des questions et
katchoo et son numéro de téléphone tout
ya passé une hyper view ont peu à peu
près tous demandé et mata les tétaniser
voleur le principe je ne sais pas j'ai
décidé d'être très calme à profiter de
votre talent
alors le voit ici on peut poser des
questions est le principe de l'hyper
viewsonic a pas ni une interview on est
deux unis perdu on est 4 4 sur vous
c'est la carence mai à 14 heures alors
qu'elle joue
vous êtes en ce moment sur scène au
bataclan dans megalopolis c'est ça
jusqu'au 30 avril ça marche
oui ça se passe très bien avec francis
lalanne qu'on a reçu les assurances
émission qui a été été formidable en
garde un bon souvenir de francis lalanne
il nous a insultés deux fois chamond
honnêtement on était on était très
content aussi
alors génial mais c'est un mec
d'éléphants j'aime beaucoup mais oui
alors attention
non vraiment il chante bien
ils sont très bien ce choix sans état
d'âme et qui tape les huissiers ne peut
pas être foncièrement mauvais
[Applaudissements]
c'est mieux que les stars qui a vécu à
l'heure aux sports d'hiver ont saisi mon
papa beaucoup mais alors megalopolis
c'est une comédie musicale engagé c'est
un peu les hippies charruel quoi c'est
un monde un peu comme ça un peu comme le
meilleur des mondes
et vous vous êtes avec la lépi toute une
bande vous êtes un peu des révoltés
contre ça c'est ça oui en fait là se
passe en 2020 et herbert pagani a écrit
cette comédie musicale en 72 et c'était
vraiment très visionnaire parce que
c'est vrai que ça il a vu en 72 qui
arrivent petit à petit dans notre
société quoi ouais et ses ouailles c'est
vrai qu'on lutte contre ça sur cette
société de communiquer de consommation
et on est toute une bande de jeunes
comme ça et c'est sympa ganil avec la
vecquerie effectivement 72 il avait
chanté tout seul à chaillot 1
et puis ailleurs je sais pas où est
ensuite le malheureux est mort je ne
savais pas moi vous savez quand on fait
gaffe ça allait le faire chanter tout ça
ils étaient tous là les chanter il faut
voir il faisait plusieurs personnages
mais vous êtes 14
c'est ça je sais que 14 pour un truc
quand il faisait tous ça tourne
absolument les seniors alors n'être pas
gagné pagani avait vu juste et vous vous
chanter juste alors ce qui a vraiment
dans tous les articles qui a eu sur
megalopolis tout le monde à 10 elle
chante juste comme s'il y avait des
doutes
un mois je vais vous chanter très très
bien paraît-il chantier maintenant c'est
vrai maintenant c'est ce que alors quand
vous jouiez dans dans les séries pour m6
et c est ce que vous jouiez aussi juste
que ce que vous chantez juste maintenant
je pense que j'ai fait des progrès
depuis mes débuts déjà tant que
comédienne puis c'était un sitcom donc
ces terres ont joué très très vite on
est pas vraiment le temps pour
travailler nos scènes et tout ça donc on
jouait comme ça quoi donc je pense que
depuis j'ai fait des progrès vous les
regardez des fois les sitcoms de m6 on
va regarder un petit boum
[Musique]
qui fait vivre et
j'ai prise au sérieux
sacré raphaël mais pourquoi il me fait
un truc pareil tu sais pour la tienne sa
portée sur mandat bons sentiments moi
c'est autre chose
je crois qu'elle est complètement mort
dif
non faut que j'y aille je vais rater
beaucoup de stretching bon allez je me
sens car elle déclaré à l'époque les
critiques m'ont fait souffrir
je me demande s'il ne vaut pas mieux
être moche vieille et sans talent ou
pensez à qui en disant ça je pense à
personne
non mais non je pensais à personne ce
qu'on m'a beaucoup traité de jolies
petites potiche et tout ça donc j'aurais
été je ne sais pas moi je revienne
vallauris je peux vous dire le plus joli
gentil merci
alors vous allez vous avez quitté aussi
toutes ces séries de m6 en disant je ne
voulais pas rester collé à vanessa
demouy toute ma vie parce que ce qu'il
faut dire effectivement c'est les excès
des siamoises n'hésitez pas c'est pas
comme ça avec avec ophélie winter et ses
soeurs de l'e sour donnait cher de l'est
et vanessa demouy la maman de vanessa
dirige l agence de mannequins s'appelle
duties où étaient amenés charlotte donc
elles étaient ensemble déjà dans l'
agence ensuite elles étaient ensemble
dans l'est dans les sitcoms voilà moi je
conduis pas tout ça je sais cette race
tout mon passé la syrie dont hélène et
les garçons y était on était passé c'est
déjà ça on peut pas tout faire non plus
dites moi justement je vais vous
demander vous avez donc elle est devenue
quoi vanessa demouy
je sais pas vous mais vous êtes vraiment
pu coller avec elle alors anne et
mallory mallaury nataf je sais pas non
plus des amicales aubry avait faironika
ça c'est mon ami en revanche pas en
parler vous êtes toujours collé à
l'oreille on est on est très amis e elt
effet beaucoup d'émissions sur mcm
l'alcool en tant qu'animatrice
elles vont bien mais vous êtes celles
qui sont les mieux sorti quand même
veronica s'en sort très bien aussi
vous êtes rencontrés tous les deux chez
arthur vrai sur les tables oui vous avez
toutes les deux de 30 et toutes les deux
sur les tables à karaoké comme des
folles oui tout à fait ça ça prouve déjà
sur la chaire turc elles savent lire
parce qu'il faut et on sait pas lire du
tout
on a juste une très bonne oreille puis
on a une mémoire auditive on sait pas
gérer ok d'arthur cgm en place qu'on
l'ait prise comme chanteuse ça c'est
formidable parce que moi à côté j'ai les
jambes dans une casserole
c'est vrai qu'on pourrait revenir dès
avec les casseroles et casseroles sa
chance bien c'est vrai méchant d'une
casse audacieux faut que ça frise dedans
vous êtes vous êtes déjà rencontré là
bas et vous allez faire chaude comme une
casserole mais je peux te dire par là
que toi tu es très court nous en être
sorti toutes les deux on les attend
maintenant on est permis de relaxer le
moment je ne sais pas on a fait un petit
pas en bonne voie avant mégalopole une
feuille pour sa mère dont jérôme gérer
donc c'est un jeu vous avez entre vous
c'est à numéros de cirque ses pieds pour
et mario et croatie alors avant
megalopolis j'ai déjà essayé de chanter
un disque sans ça on n'est pas obligé
d'en parler donc on va regarder
maintenant on va pas regarder
l'idée lors comment il s'est tourné
ensemble mais allez pas croire
la caisse est lancé son producteur de
bis bah oui c'est gore et vous que ça y
est c'est fait chanteuse mois pour finn
d'ailleurs fh me souviens bien comme l'a
fait un premier casting pour m6 lie à
quatre ans bah déjà ça modèle choisi
barca winston bérès qui nous a trouvé
les plus elle polar filmé à bruxelles
[Musique]
santé
ce rage plus faibles seraient gelées fin
en tout cas elle va être hyper jalouse
ophélie ta demi soeur mais arrête de
dire ça rien dis moi on m'a dit enfin
ouais t'as rien 18 c'est des gens qui
m'ont dit qu'elles allaient mal le
prendre
pas du tout très très très belle est
beaucoup plus mince ruban à bout et
c'est pas du tout pareil
oui c'est pas diviser les gens
applaudissent ah oui parce qu'on leur a
dit d'applaudir à part si on dépasse
maintenant ils ont applaudi spontanément
alors maintenant on va passer aux choses
sérieuses 1
quand on s'est connu tous les deux
c'était une bataille difficile on le
sait très serré parce que quand j'ai
connu quelques jours c'est vrai vous
étiez fiancée avec un jeune avocat dont
je dirais pas le prénom parce que je
suis quelqu'un c'est vrai j'ai un jeune
avocat j'ai dit ah bah non vergès il a
les cheveux teints en noir alors et vous
m'aviez dit à l'époque quand vous avez
perdu un vrai coup de foudre propos pour
ce garçon dont je ne vis pas de nom de
toute façon parce qu'en fait c'est une
réflexion ça c'est mieux vous
connaissiez devoir collard non pas
collard j'ai dit un vrai garçon car
celles non mais je dirai pas son nom des
jeunes car sound
oui les jeunes et c'est parti pour un
jeune avocat de belle roche j'ai promis
à quatre shows de pas dire son nom
d'accord sarkozy alors donc vous m'aviez
dit qu'elle fut vous m'aviez dit qu'à
l'époque vous vous étiez ensemble vous
connaissiez déjà depuis deux ans et
quand vous êtes sortis ensemble c'est
parce qu'on appelle un coup de foudre
voilà c'est tout ce que je voulais dire
en revanche mi-janvier un vrai coup de
foudre et on va voir pour kim a nié tout
c'est un mot qu'on dirait vente c'est
pour eux
quand dans séquelles mais sans corps
te
un oiseau qui étend ses ailes
% revenus
leur jeu sans en faire sourire sommet
pied
j'ai posé mes yeux
sa robe
gîte à quoi mme st
or
[Musique]
je
et celui qui je te ra
celui là on dit pas non plus pas non
maintenant principalement aujourd'hui
pas le nom pour la dernière fois de la
dernière émission va démontrer une fille
aussi qui était avec un même mec qui
chantait la même chanson alors c'est
laurent gerra laurent gerra c'est
l'original alors c'est garou c'est ça
non mais tant qu'on ne sait pas le nom
enfin c'est marrant ça vous êtes une
indiscrétion comme ça c'est d'un couple
a reconnu à mots n'ont pas nous
combattrons ce qui s'est passé non mais
a reconnu ce qu'on peut dire ce qu'on
peut dire quelque chose c'est que quand
vous êtes allé voir le spectacle
et quand vous l'avez vu sans sa bosse
dans les coulisses mais c'est la vérité
ses envies mériteriez donne ensuite la
vérité d'un journal des sites web comme
vous l'avez vu dans les coulisses sans
sa bosse au buffet qui étaient organisés
dans les coulisses vous avez vous avez
eu un coup de foudre
non mais c'est pas grave lara fabian
elle dit bien calé avec l'autre a
commencé l aciérie fiori mais attendez
c'est pas grave sur un appui de l'ibla
je me rend si yahia laquelle il ya bruno
pelletier qui est libre donc c'est un
appel que nous lançons à toutes les
françaises et notamment le chanteur
patrick fiori et en prix garou et en
prix bruno pelletier noir
sa cape elle ne servait à rien mais là
messieurs puisque michel dernier vient
de viande le pain alors taper des
gargouilles
il reste les smeralda la bei reste
esmeralda les garçons ouest esmeralda
ségara on peut dire son nom
bon je crois je vais arrêter de vous
torturer là parce que j'avais l'air dans
la dernière que je faisais une dernière
question allez-y quand on s'est connus
vous faisiez 90 63 90 aujourd'hui vous
fait combien je sais pas je me dira pas
tous les ans elles sont en fait de la
gymnastique avec des cassettes de cindy
cry j'arrête et maintenant je vais aller
dans un club de gym
ah bon et vous savez pas combien vous
mesurez banon vous savez combien vous
mesurez vos du tout dépend du bon vin
cacher je vais arrêter de vous torturer
parce que il c'est gentil mais on a été
discret et reconnaissaient leur fille
boissier robert hue
[Musique]
oui vous connaissez la sueur de
conditionnalité nicolas sable ah bon à
l'école du parti
latrèche robert bonsoir bien soit parce
que vous ayez pris lui pourquoi après
cachou lajoinie cent après que je suis
là joigny bon robert bonsoir merci
d'être là donc on peut dire que vous en
tous les cas on va faire un petit peu
votre vie comme ça parce qu on vous
entend souvent ok y'a pas de raison avec
qui je sortais dans notre dame peralda
donc maintenant on peut le dire robert
hue et avec esmeralda messieurs alors on
peut dire que vous vous avez eu la
chance d'avoir des parents communistes
alors là on va voir une photo de vous
avec votre père justement est ce qu'on
peut voir la photo de robert hue avec si
c'est pas mon père mais c'est le père
noël oui ah ouais parce que je croyais à
cause de la barre c
c'est à la sortie de l'école sont soumis
les environs rouge et qu'il a une barbe
effet ford
alors robert j'avais une mèche alain
fait gelé plus alors on va en parler
[Rires]
alors chez vous quand vous étiez petit
vous dites que on avait pas la télé pour
le couronnement d'elizabeth 2 mai pour
la visite de khrouchtchev en france quoi
celui mon âge la télé pour la visite de
khrouchtchev vous avez vraiment arrêter
là lv là dedans vous faisiez du judo
alors d'avoir une photo de vous en
judokas voilà vous avez déjà le petit
loup à vous allez il est à droite robert
hue et à droite et on voit très bien que
déjà très branché robert rouge la
ceinture noire alors donc en 62 après
sharon vous rentrez aux jeunesses
communistes en 64 à l'école du parti se
taire quand même que vous êtes un peu
sorti de nulle part mais en fait c'est
depuis 64 était en train de bosser quand
même a déjà et en 99 aujourd'hui vous
êtes secrétaire général vous êtes député
maire de montigny les cormeilles et
d'argenteuil parce que ouais ma ville
n'est pas dans la même circonscription
voilà c'est quelque chose d'un peu moins
drôle
au sujet de montigny-lès-cormeilles dans
le parisien du 2 février vous déclarer
je suis pas hostile à l'éloignement des
sauvageons c'est à dire c'est du site du
cheval à robert sauvage mais attendez
c'est vous qui le dites oui mais
chevènement et j'ai dit que je n'étais
pas contre l'éloignement de deux jeunes
qui la pagaille dans certains
quartiers mais là le formule sauvageons
ne plaît pas non je suis pour
l'éloignement déjà quelqu'un vendait
préventif pas je n'aime pas trop la
répression quand elle est nécessaire il
faut naturellement l'employé mais sinon
je suis pas trop bas alors où on l'aimé
après connaissez ça maintenant 80 déjà
ce qu'il faut dire c'est vu un petit
souci parce que vous étiez allé
manifester sous les sous les fenêtres
d'une famille immigrée d'origine
marocaine qui était accusé de trafic de
drogue et bernard henri lévy notre grand
penseur nationale avait parlé de
fascisme à la française sansonetti oui
je me souviens de cette formule qui
était complètement déplacé à mon avis je
comme mr effectivement j'avais réagi à
plusieurs morts dans dans la ville où
j'étais et puis dans les villes voisines
de la drogue c'est pas d'ailleurs
forcément de la drogue dure il y avait
des jeunes qui est et près du triple
enfin plein de choses et ça m'avait
bouleversé à l'époque j'avais réagi vous
étiez allé manifester sous les fenêtres
des valeurs sûres c'est pas vrai s'est
pas réveillé
alors vous avez déjà vais manifester
parce que je pense qu'effectivement
c'est une affaire qui appelle une
réaction de la société
ouais c'était effectivement peut-être
que je me tais je devais avant l'heure
mais bon enfin cela dit ça fait notre
succès parce que marcher georges
marchais était venu faire le premier
meeting de la campagne présidentielle
chez vous et finalement c'est comme ça
que vous êtes devenus les connais pas
enfin vraiment à lire importe si vous
disiez à l'époque les drogués sont pas
en état de faire la révolution c'est
pour ça que ça vous tout ça c'est des
formules jeu la réforme est d'accord
mais on a beaucoup disserté là dessus
c'est pas bon je veux bien qu'on parle
de cette du rapport à la tendance est
peu de chose moi par la drogue c'est bon
non mais ça ça me gêne pas parce que ma
réaction n'était pas par rapport à ces
jeunes s'étaient c'était le problème de
la drogue qui commençait déjà à pourrir
les cités à mon avis si à l'époque déjà
nous avions pris à bras le corps cette
question et en posant les poèmes de la
société parce que c'est pas la drogue
est un effets d'une crise qui existe et
danser dans ces quartiers difficiles il
y avait effectivement déjà la diffusion
une diffusion parallèle c'est qu'il n'y
a pas que dans les quartiers difficiles
oui c'est vrai c'est c'est que vous êtes
vous seriez pour la légalisation des
drogues douces non nous voir parce que
jean pêche le classement je crois que il
y à un risque réel de de passer ensuite
à la drogue dure donc je ne suis pas
d'accord
même si par ailleurs je vois bien qu'il
ya d'autres fléaux
on parle toujours de l'alcool et ça il
faut les combattre mais en même temps je
ne suis pas pour la légalisation voilà
c'est c'est clair net et sans appel pour
moi en tous les corps d'armées très bien
tout le monde était un petit peu déçue
sur le plateau à bord venait de casser
l'ambiance mais finalement c'est parce
que je pense ce qu'il dit oui je pense
que
les drogues douces amène pas forcément
donc durci ça et que au lieu de laisser
les jeunes gens fumer du pneu et de la
et de l'huile fermenté n'importe quoi de
vidange
je sais pas si c'est pas ça qui leur
fait plus de mal que le reste il est né
dans le cocon c'est vrai qu'on passe pas
forcément aux drogues dures mais on peut
il passer donc et puis moi j'ai bien vu
durable rapports entre drogues douces
ensuite d'autres produits effectivement
vous avez réservé c'est un problème
difficile et bien enfin robert est pas
tant la dépersonnalisation alors comme
ça on le sait catch où vous êtes pour ou
contre seulement l'a pas utilisé j'ai
surtout envie de le vexer
non mais vous me vexez pas du tout alors
quand vous faisiez du revenu m amp est
tel qu il est bon il est banquier comité
du rock'n'roll
robert hue cambier du rock'n'roll vous
on peut voir une photo de robert hue à
l'époque où il faisait du rock and roll
voilà donc ça s'appelait c'est un groupe
passe c'est les rapaces comment je sais
les rapaces c'est très très bien et le
nom les rapaces a été trouvé par vous
d'ailleurs oui c'est moi ce qui pour un
communiste est très fort parce qu'après
vous êtes vais passer votre vie à
combattre les rapaces se passait mieux
les vautours à l'époque les pirates ça
existe toujours le votre batteur
bassiste j'aurais ali dit que vous
chantiez pas très bien mais que vous
étiez agressif sur scène ah oui cgt à
ces révoltés sur scène c'était votre et
24 voilà répond à dire voilà on ont
révolté plus qu'énervé wet est déjà
dense et à cette époque d'ailleurs la
sete
vogue du rock and roll des groupes des
jeunes et les jeunes avec tous des
groupes moi j'allais au gold room enfin
c'était c'était quelque chose que l'on
percevait c'était une époque bénie
toujours mélangé pas énervé révolter
mais non vous montrer ce qu'est
aujourd'hui aujourd'hui quand on est un
peu révolté on dit souvent qu'il était
temps de faire la suite et si tu étais
l'ap et alors alors robert
à l'époque vous aviez vous allez vous
rêviez d'aller au golf mais vous n'avez
pas assez d'argent pour vous acheter du
matériel du matos oui c'était l'egypte
sonnent les fans des reds à côté de
derrière et donc je vais pas m'exprimer
des chansons que vous sentiez à l'époque
quelques unes mais bon si peu à peu le
large en soulevé par exemple jean
vincent hein c'est très vieux essayez
quand même bon alors donné le rythme
vous donner le rythme attention marine
bébé biba rollin admis bébé be bat for
lashes mcbb bibelots lingerie ou libé
drame horrible
[Applaudissements]
bravo bravo franges et moi j'espère
quand même que faire quand même pour lui
qu'il rate plus de voix aux européennes
en tous les cas ça donne un rapport ça
donne envie
oui ça donne envie de voter oui à sa
frappe ainsi de sa part belge allait
voter pour arlette mais maintenant je me
demande je suis en train de changer
d'avis l'empêchant de ces messieurs
c'est une bombe encore deux émissions
bravo tu le caches vient nous chanter
souchon arlette qu'on va craquer mais
moi et on peut chanter l'inter à ça je
la connaissais la lutte à vous l'avez
garder ça alors à vous avez gardé
attendez vous êtes en pleine mutation
robert adam et comprend plus rien à
l'international
on garde un droit parce que vous êtes en
sept à huit ans et mes amis de la
tangentielle d'être mieux communiste
donc l'international là vous avez gardé
la tâche donc il ya de trucs que vous
avez gardé en fait c'est la faucille et
le marteau à la une de l'humanité par
robert garder la maîtrise tsunade marché
ça vous avez gardé garder la faucille et
le marteau à la une de l'humanité vous
avez gardé l'international c'est vrai ça
l'international du jeu note que vous
n'avez pas chanter avec moi pas mais je
sais pas l'intérêt d'un vrai talent et
la lutte fila bourbon nous c'est demain
l'international
alors ni sow ni royaliste a justement
par passer on va passer à toutes les
autres pc donc vous êtes ce que vous
appelez en ce moment de votre bouquin là
que je montre à la caméra elle s'appelle
robert hue un nouveau projet enfiler
celui d'avant déjà et ça c'est le
dernier
voilà ce que tout le monde l'a bien vu
très bien vous êtes pour la mutation
c'est ça c'est à dire que maintenant
vous êtes un petit peu pour non pas le
renversement du capitalisme mais le
dépassement du capitalisme
je voulais plus renverser le capitalisme
en tous les cas je ne veux pas le
l'aménager voyez la différence qu'il y
avait qu on la démarche sociale
démocrate moi je ne suis pas pour
l'encadrer je ne suis pas pour la mairie
je suis vraiment pour changer le système
et donc le dépasser l'idée de rupture
brutale c'est vrai que on a vu que ça se
décrétait pas de supprimer le
capitalisme est allé todd pays qui
aujourd'hui ont disparu en tous les cas
en tant que système à l'est qui avait
dit on met un terme au capitalisme mais
c'est pas de le décider de décréter il
faut nous annonce banfora processus
alors je sais pas mais par exemple en ce
moment air france est en train d'être
privatisée avec un ministre communiste
qui s'appelle et non une participation
au capital dans la prise de
participations capitals ne participant
pas officiellement de la première
question à vous poser par rapport à ça
la première est ce que c'est une
question générale sur les privatisations
est ce que quand une société nationale
est privatisée est ce que l'argent
devrait pas être donné aux contribuables
qui ont financé ce truc là
en tous les cas je pense qu'il faut pas
nationalisées du tout enfin privatiser
pardon du tout là dessus c'est bien
significatif alors il est clair
qu'aujourd'hui il je pense qu'il ya trop
de privatisation oui il y avait compris
des engagements de prix de ne pas
privatiser certains grands services à
certains groupes et ils sont quand même
allés au gouvernement d'accélérer le
rythme du changement vous demandez pas
qui est de plus en plus dans les
baptisation potes qui n'ont pas de
privatisation est par contre des
réformes de structures importantes qui
permettent d'orienter l'argent autrement
déjà peu l'espoir anglais entre nous
vous acceptez quand même que air france
soit pas disons privatisées mais qui une
participation du privé au cabinet est-ce
que vous n'êtes pas un peu le gorbatchev
français est ce que vous n'êtes pas un
peu le pourquoi il est écouté
normal il ne s'en est pas mal non
j'ai pas un peu le syndic de faillite du
pays via il y a il y à une mutation
importante du parti communiste pour
rester communiste c'est bien clair c'est
pas je ne veux pas devenir social
démocrate
donc je prends l'air intéressant à faire
un test qui intéressera d'autres amis
bohringer vous préférez fidel castro ou
tony blair
je préfère fidel castro à bien des
égards on vient à cuba on peut pas
m'accuser d'anticommunisme primaire
sérieusement pas vous pensez que tout va
bien
oh non non je pensais qu'il est
suffisant vient d'un peuple qui cette
qui sait lire écrire quitte un peuple
admirable qui est un des peuples les
plus magnifique que j'ai pu croiser
je suis pas vous vous trouvez pas qu'il
ya beaucoup d'uniformes dans là je
trouve que la démocratie ça va pas ça
c'est clair mais en même temps en même
temps en même temps je suis allé à cuba
il ya un an j'ai pas vu plus uniforme
qu'ailleurs il reste que moi j'en viens
à aÿ bomba donc je sais pas je reviens
pas moi il y avait un tour de vis et le
week-end dernier
ça fait deux mois que ce qui est clair
c'est que jeune je suis effectivement
sur les questions de démocratie je pense
qu'il y a vraiment un grand pro a à
faire il reste que je partage aussi le
point de vue qui me semble être le vôtre
c'est à dire que ce blocus que subit ce
peuple est assez terrifiant et je pense
que cette petite île et son peuple ne
menace pas le le grand leader américain
à côté donc je suis pour que de ce point
de vue on lève au moins le blocus en a
compté pour vous le problème c'est le
blocus bon alors les européennes on va
re terminé que européenne les pardons
quoi oui c'est vrai robert donc les
européennes mois de blocus que vous êtes
là vous êtes pour la double parité c'est
à dire hommes-femmes commune estime que
la thèse à faire au parti communiste
vous demandez à raison je peux les aider
vos confrères
but that matter déjà c'est pas mal vous
n'êtes pas aux européennes donc votre
lycée double parité homme-femme et
communistes non communiste alors vous
avez fodé sylla vous avez roland castro
prises et a pris en main il aurait été
bien oui j'ai pensé à prendre un an il
était même d'accord même je crois qu'il
faut que bon ça pourrait se faire
c'est pas c'est pas du financement
bouclé mais quand je ne crois pas que en
même temps une faille trop mélanger et
quand braouzec le député maire de
saint-denis parle de liste attrape-tout
vidéo pc
c'est un anti east non non je ne crois
pas mais qu'on d'abord à l'epa trappe
tout mais bon vous êtes le sait s'il
était attrape-tout ali raid de jean
pierre chevènement fouine c'est pas le
cas moi j'ai noté un peu là pour les
européennes c'est compliqué il y aura
des noms communiste sur la liste
communiste y aura des gens de gauche sur
la liste pasqua une fille le pen sur la
liste mais gré c'est pas un peu le
bordel l'europe quand même hein je ne
crois pas en moins tous les cas en ce
qui concerne le parti comme il parle
pour moi il est évident que nous avons
osé faire ce que aucun autre parti n'a
fait il y à 50% des sièges sur cette
liste qui sont offerts en fait
disponible en 15 jours des non
communiste et j'ajoute pas seulement
dans la parité sur la liste parce qu'on
pourrait faire une parité sur alice mais
au niveau des élus 10 rebonds
là sur les sur les 10 premiers ou douze
premiers par exemple il y aura sinon
communiste devenu et si communiste aussi
et puis des saints dans le canard
enchaîné qui essayait de lambres paru
cette semaine mercredi on voit robert
hue il dit il y aura même sur notre
liste des communistes à 50%
vous avez dit ça c'est plus grave vous
avez dit je n'étais pas le gars qui
voyait clair avant les autres oui c'est
vrai c'est à dire que le goulag vous
saviez pas non je n'ai pas dit ça j'ai
dit dieu sinon c'est pas du tout ça
et tous ceux qui disent aujourd'hui je
savais et je mais je ne pouvais pas
faire etc
c'est pas la phrase de robert oui je la
trouve plutôt mettez pas le gars qui
voyait clair avant les eaux avait battu
se disent tous cielo du monde mais je
trouve que c'est bien de le reconnaître
et soutenir pendant la guerre ya plein
de mecs pendant la guerre il ya plein de
mecs qui disent non ça n'est pas aussi
un je trouve plutôt habile très par une
bête de scène robert savoie il a une
bonne bouille bien dire ses sympathies
il l'a fait exprès alors là on va et moi
je voudrais y venir à cette bonne
bouille parce que on va pas les faux
culs et des hypocrites et dieu sait que
moi je n'ai pas de sympathie pour le
front national est loin de là et bien au
contraire
et j'en aurais plutôt pour vous monsieur
et on sait que le pen vous a traité de
l'inde jardin et tout ça et c'est non
mais c'est vrai et c'est plutôt
sympathique finalement un le professe
preuve voilà ils croient y est mais si
on vous dit à l'époque sa douceur pour
le
d'un côté ça côté joyeux après avoir été
dans tous les jardins je vais dans
toutes les urnes c'est évident vieux pas
être agent est ce qu'il vaut mieux être
agent de kb jardin ou du kgb
j'aime bien la donald duck rouge assez
bien vous savez qu'on va passer aux
femmes vous allez rester avec nous
inquiet cache où vous restez avec nous
ça faisait plus fâché ça va aller mais
alors je passerais bien blanche neige
laissez la tranquille
les six ou non de côté chez vous
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]